en défendant son projet de loi le
gouvernement a voulu dire à l'opinion
qu'il entendait frapper les commandos
des bandes organisées
les groupes qui agissent par la violence
s'il s'agissait de cela on pourrait en
discuter
encore faudrait-il maintenir les
garanties du droit mais vous savez les
formes nouvelles de la délinquance il
n'y a rien de nouveau sous le soleil est
en réalité nos doigts notre code pénal
permettent de répondre à cette question
en vérité le gouvernement a saisi
l'occasion comme s'ils avaient voulu
profiter des circonstances pour élargir
incroyablement le la délinquance
possible
c'est ainsi que en fait il interdit
désormais le droit de manifester le
droit de se réunir et beaucoup de gens
des parents des enfants mineurs les
organisateurs de réunions ayant
l'intention d'être pacifiques les
organisateurs les chefs responsables
syndicalistes politiques les
associations professionnelles
tout tombe sous le coup de la loi
maintenant les époques extrêmement rude
ou lendemain de la révolution de 1830 au
lendemain des événements de 1934 les
ligues les ligues factieuses ou de 1936
au moment où il y avait des conflits
dans la rue on n'est jamais allé si loin
en vérité le gouvernement fait une loi
de police c'est qu'il n'a pas fait son
devoir
c'est qu'il n'a pas lui même assumer sa
responsabilité alors il demande aux
députés de la prendra sa place
c'est une mauvaise loi elle atteint tout
le monde et personne n'est en sécurité
voilà pourquoi j'ai cru devoir déposer
la question préalable
c'est à dire demander à l'assemblée
nationale de voter contre elle
[Musique]